[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
dass die ukrainische Regierung und ihre
armee-führung schon seit Monaten eine
große Gegenoffensive ankündigen hatte
sicher auch psychologische Aspekte es
half der ständig unter russischen
Beschuss stehenden Bevölkerung
durchzuhalten irgendwann schlagen wir
zurück es half auch die westlichen
Verbündeten zu motivieren und es half
den Feind nervös zu machen damit
einhergeht aber auch dass sich alle
Fragen wann geht es denn nun los mit der
Offensive möglicherweise darüber
sprechen wir gleich noch ist sie längst
im Gange mit diversen Attacken und
Täuschungsmanövern Christian Hoffmann
beginnt ihren Bericht mit Eindrücken aus
der Region saporicia nahe der Front
diese Kellerräume nennen die Bewohner
von Julia Polier ihren Punkt der
Unbesiegbarkeit eine Versorgungsstelle
in dem Ort direkt an der Frontlinie für
die da gebliebenen hier bekommen Sie
Lebensmittel aus Spenden sie können Ihre
Kleidung waschen und sich die Haare
schneiden lassen
auch olga basili war und Lydia ofcharova
kommen regelmäßig hierher
wir haben ja nichts anderes als das hier
der Markt hat noch manchmal auf und
manchmal gibt es hier Milch oder Fleisch
ein Fernseher bringt etwas Ablenkung vom
ständigen Beschuss vom Kriegsalltag seit
einem Jahr leben Sie so der Ausflug zum
Versorgungspunkt ist immer von Angst
begleitet vor Raketen vor Beschuss sie
zeigen uns ihren Unterschlupf
Kellerräume in ihrem Haus
wir sind Keller Kinder kennt ihr das
erst durch den Krieg haben sich die
beiden kennengelernt jetzt stützen sie
sich gegenseitig vor allem seit Olgas
Sohn getötet wurde
er lebte auch hier am vierten märz ging
er durch die Stadt zur Arbeit als eine
Rakete einschlug und ihn tötete
das Überleben für beide jetzt noch
schwerer
liegt in der Region wulleda im
ukrainischen Süden und hier will das
russische Militär in der Nacht eine
ukrainische Offensive zurückgeschlagen
haben der Feind habe schwere Verluste
erlitten so der Sprecher des russischen
Verteidigungsministeriums bis zu 900
ukrainische Soldaten sein getötet worden
das sei falsch antworten die Ukraine sie
vermuten das Russland vom ukrainischen
vordringen weiter nördlich bei bachmut
ablenken will hier habe die Ukraine den
Ort beriefgar zurückerobert verkündete
die stellvertretende
Verteidigungsministerin bei telegram
wir bewegen uns dort auf eine ziemlich
breiten Front wir machen Fortschritte
Söldner Chef pregorian bestätigte das
seine Kämpfe hatten das Gebiet blutig
erobert gregorge nennt den Verlust jetzt
deine Schande
ist dieses vorrücken die lange wartete
ukrainische Offensive Lilia und Olga
hoffen nicht sehnlicher als das sie
haben ausgehartem Keller unter ihrer
Wohnung weil sie kein Geld haben
wegzugehen
ihre Hoffnung ist die ukrainische Armee
die in einem Video Stille verkündet
Pläne lieben Stille heißt es da der
Anfang werde nicht verkündet
darüber wollen wir sprechen mit
Christian Mölling dem Leiter des
Zentrums Sicherheit und Verteidigung bei
der Deutschen Gesellschaft für
auswärtige Politik guten Abend Herr
mörling hallo guten Abend wie heißt das
in diesem ukrainischen Video der Anfang
wäre nicht verkündet aber möglicherweise
hat diese Offensive ja eigentlich schon
angefangen ohne dass das verkündet wird
ja ich glaube was wir auf alle Fälle
ausschließen können ist dass das hier
beginnt wie in einem amerikanischen
Hollywood Film wo morgens um 500
Trompete geblasen wird und dann fahren
irgendwelche Panzer los wir sehen ja
schon in den letzten Wochen dass es
tatsächlich ähm ausreichende Aktivitäten
gibt wo offensichtlich die ukrainische
Armee versucht herauszufinden wo die
russischen Stellungen sind wo
möglicherweise auch die Schwachpunkte
sind das ist ein bisschen katzenspiel
bei Russland natürlich immer wieder
versucht auch diese Schwächen dann
auszugleichen so richtig erfahren werden
wir glaube ich erst wenn es tatsächlich
ein die Offensive tatsächlich an
Geschwindigkeit auch Größe zugenommen
hat so dass man dann auch mehrere Bilder
davon haben wird dass man einfach nicht
mehr vermeiden können das heißt es
werden verschiedene Frontabschnitte
quasi getestet wie stark die russischen
Stellungen dort sind genau man versucht
es auf der einen Seite aufzuklären auf
der Lüfter auf der anderen Seite gibt es
bestimmte Sachen die man viel besser
natürlich vom Boden aussehen kann das
sind glaube ich so die Sachen die man
jetzt zurzeit sehen kann und natürlich
im Hinterland zurzeit die Versuche über
Sabotage die Nachschubwege zu sabotieren
und zum Teil auch offensichtlich bereits
Schläge mit Cruise Missiles aus der
Ukraine also mit lang reichweitigen
Raketen mit denen man eben auch versucht
Kommandozentralen und auch die
Versorgungswege zu treffen denn das ist
das Wichtigste also deshalb zum Beispiel
dann auch wenn in Belgorod jetzt wieder
sein ein Lager mit Treibstoff oder
ähnlichem brennt durch nach Drohnen
Beschuss genau also man versucht ja
eigentlich wenn es geht solange wie
möglich den Feind Kontakt zu vermeiden
oder die Bedingungen für sich selber so
gut wie möglich zu machen weil der Krieg
natürlich immer sehr viele
Unwegbarkeiten mit sich bringt so dass
man versucht das am besten das
Gefechtsfeld am besten für sich soweit
vorzubereiten bevor man tatsächlich dann
auf den Gegner trifft
insgesamt hat es aber doch lange
gedauert mit der Offensive also es war
ja anfangs eine Frühlingsoffensive und
jeder wartet drauf und wartet heißt dass
die Ukraine warten vor allen Dingen auch
noch darauf dass es mehr westliche
Waffen gibt darüber können wir glaube
ich zu Zeit nur spekulieren das kann das
sein es kann sein dass man auch
tatsächlich noch auf den richtigen
Moment wartet oder auch dass man hofft
dass über diese Spannung die jetzt
erzeugt wird tatsächlich auch Moskau
nervöser wird und dass man auch dass der
andere Möglichkeit auch versucht die ja
doch sehr hochgefahrene fast
überkochende Erwartungshaltung in den
westlichen Gesellschaften wieder ein
bisschen runterkommen zu lassen wir
haben ja Wochen gehabt wo im Wohnraum
jeder jede Minute darauf gewartet hat
dass sie Offensive beginnt das ist aber
glaube ich eine völlig falsches Bild als
ob sozusagen so ein kipppunktgeber die
man sagen könnte jetzt gibt's nur
offensiver aber alle fragen sich
natürlich wo und welche Richtung wird
sie gehen
genau das ist total legitim und die
Ukraine wird es uns schlauerweise nicht
erzählen denn dann würde sie ja das
Überraschungsmoment verlieren
danke für das Gespräch
so jetzt machen wir mit einem ganz
anderen Thema weiter nämlich mit Corona
Corona ist zwar aus den Schlagzeilen
verschwunden aber es ist nicht aus der
Welt schon gar nicht für Patienten die
an Langzeitfolgen dieser Virusinfektion
leiden laut einer aktuellen
internationalen Studie sind weltweit ca
65 Millionen Menschen von Long kobit
betroffen das Virusinfektion bei manchen
Menschen extreme Langzeitfolgen haben
können das weiß man schon länger nicht
nur kovid kann das Auslösen allerdings
ist longkowith ein sehr viel eingängiger
Begriff als
mecfs die medizinische Abkürzung für das
chronische fatig-syndrom insofern hat
die corona-pandemie diesen Erkrankungen
zumindest eine größere Öffentlichkeit
verschafft
eine der weltweit führenden
ForscherInnen auf diesem Gebiet wurde
heute mit dem hochtotierten else Kröner
freseniuspreis ausgezeichnet auf ihre
Forschung richten sich die Hoffnungen
von Betroffenen Susanna Bericht
kann ich dir die Maske bringen damit ich
reinkommen kann
wenn Sonja Bauer zu ihrer Tochter ins
Zimmer gehen möchte dann muss sie sich
ankündigen vor dem Zimmer trotz
geschlossener Tür ein schalldämmender
Vorhang
Layla ist ein mecfs erkrankt einer
schweren neuroimmunologischen Erkrankung
24 Stunden am Tag ist die 26-Jährige ins
Bett gefesselt er trägt kein Licht keine
Geräusche keine Berührung
sie kann nicht alleine essen sie kann
nicht lesen sie kann leider nicht mehr
Musik hören im Grunde genommen liegt sie
den ganzen Tag im Bett und kann nichts
tun also einfach eigentlich bin ich
schon tot nur bin ich noch da
und da zuständige Schmerzen auch
psychisch geht es leider schlecht als
mcfs bei ihr ausbrach wollte sie gerade
Abitur machen war ausgezogen
wahrscheinlich war es bei ihr eine
genetische Vorerkrankung und die
Infektion mit dem sogenannten
Epstein-Barr-Virus das mcfs auslöste
eine kaum erforschte Krankheit die durch
die corona-pandemie ins Bewusstsein
gerückt ist denn viele die mit dem
Corona-Virus infiziert waren sind auch
daran erkrankt eine besonders schwere
Form von nonkovit
und sie forscht schon seit 20 Jahren zur
Immunantwort bei viralen Infektionen
Akiko übersaki wurde in Frankfurt mit
dem Elsa grüner freseniuspreis
ausgezeichnet dotiert mit 2,5 Millionen
Euro
es ist eine große Ehre für mich aber es
spricht auch für die Stiftung die
anerkennt dass er mit CFS und lukowit
weltweite Bedeutung haben
für mich würde ein Traum wahr werden
wenn ich diesen Menschen die so leiden
helfen könnte wenn ich heilen dann
wenigstens helfen damit es Ihnen ein
bisschen besser geht
mit ihrer Forschung unter anderem
festgestellt dass bei Betroffenen
latente Herpesviren die viele Menschen
im Körper haben plötzlich reaktiviert
werden außerdem hatten viele einen
niedrigen Cortisolspiegel was zu
Gewichtsverlust Müdigkeit und Schwäche
führen kann warum muss sie weitere
Forschung zeigen
das Besondere an ihrer Arbeit sei dass
sie damit auch die Krebsforschung
vorantreiben sagt die Jury die
wichtigsten neuen
Immuntherapie gegen Tumoren die sind
alle entdeckt worden weil wir verstanden
haben wie unsere Immunsystem Viren
erkennen deswegen ist ihr Beitrag auch
weit über die Virologie hinaus sondern
ihre Erkenntnisse können auch genutzt
werden um neue Immuntherapien gegen
Tumorerkrankungen zu entwickeln
über jede Forschung dankbar eine
Viruserkrankung hat die Leben völlig
verändert das wird sie mit Sicherheit
nicht ihr Leben lang machen wollen
und sie ist Mitglied in einem
sterbehilfeverein und das aus gutem
Grund weil sie sagt ich will so nicht
leben seit mittlerweile acht Monaten
geht es leider so ohne jede Besserung
noch mal zum Glück zurück zum Krieg
gegen die Ukraine er begleitet die
deutsche Außenministerin auch auf ihrer
Brasilien Reise die große Frage ist ob
Brasilien dieses riesige Land mit Blick
auf den Krieg in Europa überhaupt eine
Rolle spielen kann unter dem
Rechtspopulisten bolzenario hatte sich
Brasilien weltpolitisch ziemlich ins
ausgestellt als Anfang des Jahres der
Linkspolitiker Lula an die Macht
zurückkehrte weckte das gerade in Europa
große Hoffnungen die bislang aber eher
enttäuscht wurden als potentieller
Vermittler im Ukraine Krieg scheint sich
Lula weitgehend diskreditiert zu haben
auf viele wirkt er wie aus der Zeit
gefallen Christoph
die bundesaußenministerin allein vor dem
Präsidentenpalast in Brasilia der
Hausherr ist nicht zu sehen
Deutschlands Beziehungen zu Brasilien
gelten als gut doch in letzter Zeit
lassen Bilder und Worte Raum für
Interpretationen und Unsicherheiten vor
allem in Bezug auf den Ukraine Krieg
immer wieder hat der brasilianische
Präsident Lula das Silva mit seinen
Äußerungen für Unmut gesorgt
weder Russland noch Ukraine wollen den
Krieg beenden die Entscheidung zum Krieg
ist in zwei Ländern gefallen die USA
müssen aufhören den Krieg zu befeuern
und über Frieden reden
beim G7 Gipfel bleibt er sitzen während
die anderen Staats- und Regierungschefs
aufstehen um den ukrainischen
Präsidenten selinski persönlich zu
begrüßen
ob beabsichtigt oder nicht ist unklar
aber die Episode steht sinnbildlich für
das schwierige Verhältnis Brasiliens zu
Ukraine
[Musik]
gleichzeitig die offizielle Position
Brasiliens sei die russische Invasion zu
verurteilen doch er selbst scheint hier
weniger entschlossen
mit der Abhängigkeit der mächtigen
brasilianischen Agrarindustrie von
russischem Dünger ist das kaum zu
erklären
eher schon mit der Tradition der
equidistanz dem gleichen Abstand zu den
großen Mächten der Welt vor allem zu den
in Südamerika immer wieder aktiven USA
sucht Brasilien ein Gegengewicht
unabhängig von der ideologischen
Ausrichtung ist Brasiliens wichtigstes
nationales Interesse die Beziehungen zu
anderen Großmächten aufrecht zu erhalten
um der Dominanz Washingtons etwas
entgegenzusetzen
das zeigt sich nicht nur am Verhältnis
Brasiliens zu Russland sondern auch zu
China die engen Beziehungen möchte Lola
weiter ausbauen auf festliche Kritik
daran reagiert Lula im chinesischen
Fernsehen kämpferisch
[Musik]
Jahrzehnte lang waren nur eine Handvoll
Länder reich und mächtig und
beherrschten Welt das jetzt Länder wie
China Indien und Brasilien stärker
werden bereitet denjenigen und Behagen
die sich bisher als Herrscher der Welt
gesehen haben
eine Weltordnung Jenseits westlicher
Dominanz möglich dass dies Lulas
eigentliche Agenda ist und auch die
Distanz erklärt die heute in Brasilia zu
spüren ist keine Gespräche auf oberster
Ebene stattdessen mit dem
Vizepräsidenten und dem außenpolitischen
Berater Lukas aber ohne Presse und ohne
gemeinsames Statements Deutschlands Chef
Diplomatin nimmt es diplomatisch wir
blicken auf die Vergangenheit sicherlich
in manchen Bereichen unterschiedlich
auch mit Blick auf die Rolle Russlands
aber ich habe stark dafür geworben dass
wir gemeinsam unsere Zukunft in Frieden
weltweit nur bauen können wenn wir an
einem Strang ziehen der Wunsch bleibt
zurück in Brasilia und die
Außenministerin zieht weiter
gesehen nicht nur Außenministerin
Brasilien auch Arbeitsminister Heil ist
dorthin gereist mit einem
anwerbungsprogramm im Koffer damit geht
es bei dir jetzt weiter Hans es geht
darum ausländische Fachkräfte für
Deutschland zu gewinnen vor allem
Pflegekräfte in der Hauptstadt Brasilia
besuchte Heil eine Pflegeschule er
verwies darauf dass in Deutschland in
der Pflege der Bedarf an Fachkräften
groß sein während es in Brasilien einen
Überhang an gut ausgebildeten Kräften
gebe 200 brasilianische Pflegekräfte
arbeiten derzeit schon in Deutschland
die Bundesagentur für Arbeit hält die
Anwerbung von bis zu 700 pro Jahr für
möglich
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat sich auf der
Ostsee vor Rostock ein Bild von den
Fähigkeiten der deutschen Marine gemacht
von der Fregatte Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
aus beobachtete Scholz verschiedene
Übungen vor der Küste deutschland hat
mit Jahresbeginn die Führung der
schnellen Eingreiftruppe der NATO
übernommen an der auch die Marine in der
Ostsee beteiligt ist
Polen hat im Streit mit der EU um die
Unabhängigkeit von Richtern vor dem
Europäischen Gerichtshof eine endgültige
Niederlage erlitten nach einem heute
verkündeten Urteil verstoßen Teile der
polnischen Justizreform von 2019 gegen
EU-Recht laut EuGH habe insbesondere die
inzwischen abgeschaffte Disziplin
nahkammer für Richter deren
Unabhängigkeit untergraben Polen war
deswegen zuvor schon zu einem Zwangsgeld
verurteilt worden
die Staatsanwaltschaft Halle hat Anklage
gegen den Thüringer afd-fraktionschef
höcke erhoben ihm werde das öffentliche
Verwenden von Kennzeichen eine
ehemaligen nationalsozialistischen
Organisation zu Last gelegt teilte die
Staatsanwaltschaft mit er werde
verdächtigt in eine Rede auf einer
Wahlkampfveranstaltung im Mai 2021 eine
verbotene Losung verwendet zu haben laut
Staatsanwaltschaft habe höcke über seine
Verteidigung die strafrechtliche
Relevanz seiner Äußerung in Abrede
gestellt
Deutschland und fünf weitere europäische
Länder wollen künftig gemeinsam
verstärkt gegen organisierte
Drogenkriminalität Vorgehen
bundesinnenministerin Felser und
Minister aus Belgien Italien Spanien
Niederlande und Frankreich mit Hunden
bei einem treffendem belgischen
Antwerpen wie wichtig es sei auch
künftig verschlüsselte Kommunikation
zwischen kriminellen abfangen zu können
auch soll in den Häfen der Schutz vor
Drogen Schmuggel verstärkt werden
als prominente Experten und Silicon
Valley Unternehmer letztens vor den
Risiken künstlicher Intelligenz warnten
und dabei klang wie die mythische
Kassandra hat das sehr hohe Wellen
geschlagen rief aber auch Kritik hervor
die
weltuntergangswarnung sei er eine
PR-Aktion und sie würden damit zwar
Schlagzeilen trächtig die eigene
Bedeutung unterstreichen um sich
zugleich aber aus der Verantwortung
stehlen nach dem Motto hey Leute wir
haben es euch ja gesagt ist gefährlich
dazu passt dass sich einige der großen
techfirmen inzwischen konzilianter
gegenüber staatlichen
regulierungsversuchen zeigen sich auf
freiwillige Selbstverpflichtungen
einzulassen tut nicht weh macht aber
einen guten Eindruck so zeigten sich
Google und Co heute in Brüssel offen für
weitere Regeln gegen das Information
Florian neuhahn erklärt was ist damit
auf sich hat
am Anfang muss man vielleicht noch
schmunzeln wenn der französische
Präsident angeblich nicht mehr kann
wenn der deutsche Vizekanzler
vermeintlich live im Fernsehen ausrastet
du redest wie ein Frosch Robert halten
Sie doch endlich mal ihre dumme Fresse
Frau Maischberger oder wenn sich der
russische Kriegsherr scheinbar auf
Englisch an die US-Bevölkerung wendet
wir danken
nach dem schmunzeln aber kommt die Angst
weil es nur noch wenige Mausklicks
braucht Menschen irgendetwas sagen zu
lassen und weil selbst Experten nicht
immer sicher sind was ist wahr was Fake
es gibt mittlerweile Fakes die wirklich
sehr sehr gut sind wo es auch mir schwer
fällt Ungereimtheiten und Fehler zu
erkennen und potenziell ist das
natürlich eine sehr große Gefahr für die
Gesellschaft und was sie an diesem
Morgen auch hier besprechen
EU-Kommission Brüssel fast alle
wichtigen internetplayer sind gekommen
Europa will den bestehenden
Verhaltenskodex auf die neuen
Möglichkeiten anpassen
Farmer User für normale Nutzer soll auch
wenn sie abgelenkt sind ab sofort direkt
erkennbar sein dieses Foto dieses Video
hier wurde nicht von echten Menschen
gemacht
sondern hier spricht eine Maschine
ein Label also für künstliche
Intelligenz um zu verhindern dass
Manipulation im Netz Meinung macht
vorerst aber liegt es an den Konzernen
wie Google allein künstlich erstellte
Inhalte zu erkennen sie zu markieren und
vorläufig tun sie das bloß freiwillig
besser so sagen sie bei der FDP
wenn wir zu schnell regulieren ohne alle
Auswirkungen auch zu kennen dann laufen
wir eine Überregulierung rein und dann
laufen wir Gefahr den textstandort
Europa abzuhängen doch wie das so ist
mit der Freiwilligkeit ein
Internetkonzern hat sich schon
verabschiedet Twitter unter Eigentümer
Elon Musk er will Europas Codex nicht
länger anerkennen und Brüssel droht mit
Strafzahlungen die mit einem Gesetz bald
möglich sein können
[Musik]
sich für Konfrontation entschieden aber
täuschen sie sich nicht diese
Entscheidung hat sehr viel
Aufmerksamkeit auf sich gezogen wie
Twitter sich nun an EU-Gesetze hält das
wird ab sofort genauestens überprüft
werden
gern hätten wir gehört wie der Twitter
Konzern auf diese Drohung reagiert auf
unsere Presseanfrage kommt die Antwort
auch postwendend direkt von einem
Roboter
sie besteht nur aus diesem einen Zeichen
und mit dem Blick auf die deutsche
Wirtschaft geht es bei dir jetzt noch
mal weiter Heinz und zwar konkret mit
der Exportwirtschaft nach einem
durchwachsenen Jahresauftakt haben die
Ausfuhren von März auf april wieder
zugelegt meldet der Statistische
Bundesamt anhand von vorläufigen Daten
also ein auf- und ab war der realer wie
rund läuft der Exportmotor nicht mehr so
rund wie die vergangenen Jahre
tatsächlich eher so in einem
Zickzackkurs der Zuwachs im April das
ist zwar ein Hoffnungsschimmer aber
sicher noch keine Trendwende um 1,2%
sind die Experte im Vergleich zum
Vormonat gestiegen überraschend zumal
sie im März noch um 6% eingebrochen
waren Abnehmer Land Nummer eins bleiben
die USA allerdings erwarten
Handelsexperten auch hier einen Rückgang
bei der Nachfrage der Export ist eben
nicht mehr so stark wie er einmal war
dafür ist die Weltkonjunktur einfach zu
schwach hierfür gibt es mehrere Gründe
die hohe Inflation
stark gestiegene Zinsen und eine
weltweit gedämpfte Nachfrage es liegt
aber nicht nur an der Weltkonjunktur
auch an Schwellenländern wie China die
immer häufiger in der Lage sind ihre
Investitionsgüter selbst zu produzieren
besonders aber beim deutschen
Exportschlager schlechthin dem Auto ist
ungewiss ob es nach der elektrowende
noch so wettbewerbsfähig ist wie heute
sensible Technologien dürfen nicht mehr
so einfach exportiert werden vor allem
in Länder wie China andere schotten sich
ab empfehlen ihren Bürgern verstärkt
heimische Produkte zu kaufen all das
macht es Deutschland schwerer seine
Waren in die Welt zu verkaufen der
Export also eigentlich Wachstumsmotor
der Konjunktur ist ins Stottern geraten
vielen Dank
beide sozialdemokratischen Partei
Österreichs SPÖ hat es bei der Wahl zum
Vorsitzenden am Wochenende eine schwere
Panne gegeben wodurch der falsche
Kandidat zum Parteichef gekürt wurde
Hans-peter doskozil war als Sieger
bekannt gegeben worden aber bei der
Übertragung einer Tabelle seiner
Ergebnisse vertauscht worden und so habe
tatsächlich dessen Konkurrent Andreas
Gabler gewonnen wie die Wahlkommission
heute bekannt gab
stimmen
er war der erste Mensch der die 100
Meter in unter zehn Sekunden lief und
damit 1968 Sportgeschichte schrieb nun
ist der US-Amerikaner Jim Heinz im Alter
von 76 Jahren verstorben wie heute
bekannt wurde bei den US-Meisterschaften
1968 Sieg der Heinz mit einer Hand
gestoppten Weltrekordzeit von 9,9
Sekunden kurz darauf bei den Olympischen
Spielen in Mexiko statt gewann er das
100 m Finale sogar in elektronisch
gestoppten
9,95 Sekunden im selben Jahr beendet
Heinz seine Karriere als Sprinter seine
Weltrekord aber hielt noch weitere 15
Jahre
[Applaus]
im Streit um den Umgang mit sogenannter
Beutekunst nehmen die Benin Bronzen seit
langem eine Sonderstellung ein nicht nur
weil sie zweifelsfrei Raubgut waren und
von Nigeria seit langem zurückgefordert
wurden auch weil sie von hohen
künstlerischen Wert sind kostbar in
Material handwerklich in zeitloser
Perfektion sie beeindruckten die
Europäer auch deshalb weil sie so
europäisch wirkten
die neue Bundesregierung hat bekanntlich
beschlossen sie an Nigeria zurückzugeben
ein Teil wurde schon ausgehändigt das
Problem ist nur nicht dass nigerianische
Volk hat sie zurückbekommen sondern ein
Königshaus das selbst in den
Sklavenhandel verstrickt war das sorgt
weiterhin für Ärger wie Andrea Maurer
berichtet
ein feierlicher Moment kurz vor
Weihnachten 2022
Außenministerin und
kulturstaatsministerin sind nach Nigeria
gereist um die ersten 20 Benin brancen
persönlich zurückzugeben
den sie gehören den Menschen in Nigeria
wem in Nigeria die Branchen gehören das
ist damals schon umstritten Deutschland
übergibt sie dem nigerianischen Staat
hofft dass sie öffentlich gezeigt werden
im März aber übereignet der scheidende
nigerianische Präsident sie an ihn den
Ober von Benin Nachfahre der
Königsfamilie aus deren Palast die
brancen 1897 von den Briten geraubt und
nach Deutschland verkauft worden waren
seitdem ist auch von deutscher Naivität
die Rede wir treffen die
kulturstaatsministerin zum Interview
natürlich wurde in einer gemeinsamen
Erklärung im Juli letzten Jahres ja
vereinbart dass öffentliche Zugang zu
diesen Kunstwerken besteht aber was
jetzt passiert mit den Branchen das hat
der Besitzer zu entscheiden und das ist
der souveräne Staat Nigerias
längst sind die brancen Gegenstand
aufgeregter Debatten Mitte Mai Bundestag
diese Bundesregierung vertreten durch
die Ministerinnen Claudia Roth und
Annalena baerbock hat Deutschland in der
Welt blamiert und der Demütigung
preisgegeben die Union will weitere
Rückgaben vorerst stoppen wir werden in
der nächsten Sitzungswoche als
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion einen Antrag
diesbezüglich einbringen wo wir auch
fordern als Bundestagsfraktion an die
Bundesregierung das sichergestellt
werden muss dass diese Branchen dann
auch öffentlich zugänglich gemacht
werden ich bin ehrlich gesagt über die
Reaktionen bei uns in der Bundesrepublik
sehr erstaunt und irritiert oder man
könnte auch sagen sie stören mich
wirklich massiv also dieser alte
koloniale
Paternalismus wir wissen wie man mit
Kunst umgeht der Afrikaner in
Anführungszeichen weiß es nicht der muss
doch überwunden werden noch im Dezember
war die kulturstaatsministerin nach
Benin City gereist mit deutschen Geldern
wird hier ein öffentliches Museum gebaut
dass Adam Museum auf West African Art 5
Millionen Euro für einen ersten Pavillon
ob die Bronzen und hier gezeigt werden
können ist offen Verhandlung mit dem
Ober von Berlin laufen die
pavillonleiterin bittet um mehr Geduld
die Rückgabe von Raubkunst ist kein
einmaliges Ereignis sondern einfach
handlungsprozess wir haben immer gesagt
Restitution endet nicht mit der Übergabe
der Branchen
auch wenn die brancen Deutschland nie
rechtmäßig gehört haben lassen sie
Deutschland offenbar nicht los
verhandelt wird mit ihnen auch das
Verhältnis zur Kolonialgeschichte das
Verhältnis zu Afrika
das war von uns gleich nach dem Wetter
geht es mit dem ZDF montagskino weiter
und um 0 Uhr gibt's dann unsere heute
journal Update mit Gundula Gause auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend jetzt kommt Bewegung ins
Wetter und das liegt an diesem Höhentief
das bringt Regenwolken mit aber auch
Schauer und Gewitter so wird es heute
Nacht vor allen Dingen am Nordrand des
Erzgebirges kräftiger regnen aber auch
in Bayern sonst ist es häufig klar und
die Temperaturen sinken auf 14 bis 6
Grad die Höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen zwischen 16 Grad an der Nordsee
und dem Vogtland und bis zu 27 Grad in
der Uckermark am Niederrhein in Sachsen
fällt morgen häufig Regen und auch in
Thüringen regnet es und bis zum Abend
erreichen die Regenwolken auf das
südliche Niedersachsen Sachsen-Anhalt
und Brandenburg und am Nachmittag kann
es dann auch immer mal wieder für
Gewitter reichen zum Beispiel hier in
Bayern sonst bleibt's bei Sonne und wohl
am Mittwoch regnet es dann auch mal im
Westen Deutschlands der Donnerstag wird
eher durchwachsen und der Freitag am
Oberrhein heiß mit bis zu 30 Grad in
Nordosten fällt kein Regen und so bleibt
die Waldbrandgefahr bis Freitag dort
sehr hoch
große Feuer bedingen enorme Hitze bis zu
1.200 Grad Hitze steigt auf es entsteht
ein starker Sog am Boden strömt Luft
nach frischer Sauerstoff der saust bis
zu 100 km/h schnell ins feuerzentrum und
facht das Feuer weiter an Prinzip
Blasebalg die heiße Luft wird Kilometer
hoch katapultiert es bildet sich eine
feuerwolke manchmal gar ein pyrocumulo
Nimbus eine gigantische Gewitterwolke
Blitze können neue Brände auslösen
bildet sich regen löst der sich schnell
wieder auf und kühlt die Luft die
kühlere Luft ist schwerer sinkt ab
rasend schnell zum Teil diese Fallböen
entfachen neue Feuer damit all das nicht
passiert vermeiden Sie Funkenflug guten
Abend